Okay, while while the projector is
starting up
let me get started.
See some familiar
Yes. I see some familiar faces around.
How many of you are in my corporate
finance class?
You came back for more punishment?
What's wrong with you? Hey?
Um
The rest of you were not in my corporate
How many of you are not full-time MBAs?
So Langone So how many of you are not at
the Stern School? You're in the in
another graduate school? Anybody here?
Just a note of caution, much of the
stuff that happens in this class, we
want to get on the Google shared for
instance our the shared spreadsheet that
I sent you would require Stern email
address.
And if you're not at Stern, you don't
have one, I will send you actually a
little way of There is a Stern email
address that's created for you the
moment you join a Stern class. I want
you to be aware of that because that way
you'll make sure you get emails and also
that you can get on Capital IQ, be able
to get data. So you should get that
with an email after class today.
So with no further ado,
this is valuation.
I hope you're in the right class. In
case you're not, this is the time to
leave.
And it's been an interesting day, right?
How does a company lose almost a
trillion dollars in market cap in one
day? Well, you found out today, right?
Can one thing happening over the weekend
change your entire perspective on
what's coming in the future? Yes, right?
We live in interesting times, and that's
why I guess the Chinese have that as a
curse, may you live in interesting
times.
Now, this has always been an interesting
class to teach. A little bit of history
of this class. I came to NYU in 1986.
Now, I'm getting old. My kids remind me
of this, and I'm reminded every time I
get an elevator and I run into somebody
whose parent went through this class.
Thank God, no grandparents yet, but it's
only a matter of time. Um
But, when I came to NYU in 1986, I was
given a class to teach.
It was called security analysis.
Heard of this class? Class with a very
long and hoary tradition.
Class that was taught at Columbia
University by a guy called Ben Graham.
If you haven't heard of Ben, you've
heard of his most famous student.
Any names?
Warren Buffett. The class He had a class
of only five people. I don't know,
either he was not a very good teacher or
very restrictive requirements to get
into this class. The class had been
taught since the 1950s. So, 1986, they
give me this class to teach. I take one
look at the class and
my response I don't want to teach this
class.
Most boring class ever.
Cuz by 1986, it was showing its age.
It was four weeks on stocks and three
weeks on bonds and two weeks on futures
and options.
And five weeks on institutional detail.
Like what? There was an entire session
on listing requirements for the New York
Stock Exchange.
Teaching was so easy in the days before
Wikipedia.
You could actually go in in front of a
classroom, list out all the
requirements. Remember, these were the
days people had to take everything down.
There were no slides.
And you could walk out looking like a
genius. I couldn't even try that
anymore.
So, I went to the head of my department
and I said, "I don't want to teach this
class." Terrible attitude for an
assistant professor. He should have
fired me on the spot, but he was a good
guy. He said, "What would you like to
teach instead?"
I said, "I'd like to teach evaluation
class."
He said, "Don't do it."
He said, "There isn't enough stuff in
valuation
to fill a class." And you know what? He
was absolutely right. In 1986,
there wasn't enough stuff in valuation
to fill a class.
You know the only valuation book that
was out there?
Book called Security Analysis written by
Ben Graham. You know what When the first
edition of the book was? What year?
1934. And I want you to think about
that. What was happening, you think, in
1934 in the US?
You're coming off the Great Depression,
right?
If you read Security Analysis, it reeks
of risk aversion.
It's just,
you know, it's about safety.
And who can blame Ben Graham for putting
safety first? But by 1986,
the book was showing its age.
Right? It was a book where you wanted to
buy a stock
that behaved like a bond. That's
basically what Ben Graham's Security
Analysis was. The dividends came in for
the coupons, you collected your cash
flows, and you got some upside. Great,
you get all the stuff that you get with
a bond plus the upside.
He said, "Don't do it."
You're saying, "What about the CFA?"
There was no CFA in 1986. There'd be
probably three people had taken it. I
don't know. It's Nobody There were no
valuation places you could go for the
material.
But I really, really wanted to teach
this class.
And I discovered very early in my
experiences with the universities
that if you want to get anything done at
a university, the best way to do it is
to do it subversively.
Cuz if you ask for official permission,
you know what would happen, right? A
committee will be formed.
Yeah, do you guys have experience with
committees being formed? They form, they
meet, they meet, they keep meeting, they
forget what they're meeting about, but
they keep meeting anyway. Then there are
baby committees that they call
subcommittees and sub-subcommittees.
And by the time they got back to me,
maybe 35 years later and say you can
teach the class, I'd be too old to do
it.
So I said, I'll teach your security
analysis class.
I walked in closed the door. And
remember, these were the days before
there were cameras in the classroom.
Forget about recording, that was all not
even on the realm of possibilities.
And I taught a valuation class.
They had no idea what I do inside the
classroom. I could be teaching cooking
for 15 weeks, and as long as everybody
got an A, nobody was complaining.
It was fall of 1986.
This class, I'm teaching two version two
variants of this class. One to the
undergraduates, one to the MBAs. And I
teach exactly the same class to both.
See, but they're undergraduates.
21-year-olds with just as much brain
power as MBAs do. There's nothing
magical about valuation. It's exactly
the same class. It's my 59th and 60th
semester teaching this class. And I'm
going to say something about this class
that will encapsulate
how I talk about valuation, think about
valuation, write about valuation.
Everything I know about valuation I've
learned in the course of teaching this
class.
Let me back that up.
It was the fall of 1987, my third
semester teaching at NYU. And at that
time, NYU's graduate business school was
downtown, right next to the American
Stock Exchange. That building is still
there. It's been taken over by the New
York public school system, I think. But
at that time, it was a graduate business
school.
I always teach Monday once, I'm a
creature of habit.
So, it's
I can name the date. It was October 19th
of 1987.
I taught my valuation class. It was from
9:00 to 10:30.
And I come back to my office, I look out
of my window, and I see that everybody
from the exchange floor is out on the
street.
What happened?
Maybe a fire alarm went off.
Does anybody know what happened on
October 19th of 1987 that drove those
people onto the street?
Black Monday.
It was a Black Monday, but there've been
a lot of Black Mondays. We have to get
more specific. This was a particularly
Black Monday. The S&P 500 on that day
dropped by 22%.
We're freaking out about the market drop
today. We're talking about a 2% drop.
Think about a drop 10 times larger and
think of how much more you'd be freaking
out.
One-day drop, 22%. Biggest single-day
drop in market history. It was Monday.
Wednesday, I come back in front of my
class. Guess what the first question I
was asked was?
"How with your valuation tools can you
explain the entire market dropping by
22%?" I can't duck and weave, right? I
mean, you ask me, "How can Nvidia drop
by 20% or 16%?" I can duck and weave and
tell you a story about the But this is
the entire market.
How does that happen? I would like be
lying if I told you I had the answer,
but I have this very bad habit that my
kids point out to me, which is I can't
say I don't know.
I've got to figure it out. And I figure
out in real time. So, I said, "I don't
know, but let's think about what can
cause the entire market to correct?
The process that I started that day is a
process I still go back to when markets
go through crisis.
I went through it you know in 2020 with
the COVID crisis. I went back to what I
learned in 1987. But I didn't even think
about that question until it happened in
real time and I was asked, "How do you
explain that?"
Fast forward to the 1990s and you see
something you'd never seen in public
markets before.
Companies with lots of potential but
with unformed business models going
public.
Those companies had always been around
but before the 1990s, where did they get
their funding?
Venture capitalists.
For the first time they went to They
skipped a step. They went directly to
public markets. I'm talking of course
about the dot-com boom. I remember the
day in 1997.
This is class just like this one by
then. Might been in this room. I got
shifted to Paulson right after so, you
know,
somebody I don't know, third row, fourth
row puts up her hand. She says, "Can we
value this company called amazon.com?"
I said, "I don't see why not."
You know what kind of company Amazon was
in 1997? It was an online book retailer.
That's all they sold is books.
Lots of potential.
Nothing to show for it yet.
And we valued amazon.com and in fact I
kept a journal of what of every road
block I ran into in valuing Amazon
because there was nothing in the
literature, nothing in the practice
about how to estimate revenues for a
company with no financials.
How to come up with the risk for a
company with no history.
How to come up with comparables when the
peer group all looks just like Amazon,
all young companies with lots of
potential.
To show you how many road blocks I ran
into by the time I was done,
the journal was 74 pages long.
And I never throw away anything I write.
So, I slapped the title on it. The dark
side of valuation, can amazon.com be
valued? It's still on my website
somewhere, cuz it's good to have your
history staring you in the face.
Cuz you can't then run away say, "I
never said that."
Everything I know about valuing young
companies I learned in the process of
valuing Amazon in 1997. So, if you see
my Zomato valuation from 2021, you see
the residue of what I what I learned
when I valued Amazon in 1997.
And you fast forward another 11 years,
it's 2008. You're in a market crisis,
but one caused by banks behaving badly.
And again,
early in 2009, somebody raises his hand,
he says, "Why when banks behave badly do
the rest of us feel the pain?"
Introduced the word we used on about
systemic risk, the fact that when banks
take on risks, it's not just banks that
are affected, it's the entire economy.
And again, I hadn't thought through
this. Why if I'm valuing Walmart do I
care about banks behaving badly?
But in early 2000, there was no way
around it. Every company you valued,
this was a subtext. What will happen to
banks? Will they get healthy again?
But again, I hadn't thought about it
until it came up.
Then you get to the last decade.
You get the decade of what I call the
numbers company.
What am I talking about? Let's take
Facebook.
Or Meta as they prefer to call
themselves now.
What's the most impressive number about
Meta?
They don't have subscribers, remember?
They have people on their platforms,
right?
How many people are on the Meta
platform? So, remember that includes
WhatsApp. How many of you are on
WhatsApp?
I last time I was in India, I don't
think you can function in India without
WhatsApp now. It's become this vehicle
through
3 billion people on Facebook, on
Instagram and WhatsApp.
That's a mind-boggling number. One out
of every two adults in the face of the
earth
is on the Facebook ecosystem. You know
how much time they spend there?
57 minutes a day.
You You lay your claim on 1 hour of
every walking human being's time, hey,
you got the basis for an incredible
value.
The most impressive number about Netflix
is not the number of bad shows that
produce, but that's rising up the ranks.
I mean, now you got to look through 10
shows before you can find a watchable
show on Netflix. Seven different
languages and you're navigating through
and so what I don't even know what that
is.
Most impressive number though is almost
300 people who are subscribers
who pay 22.99 or 25 or 10 or 15 a month
every month.
So again, 2017. I value Netflix in my
class the conventional way, project
revenues, margins, cash flows,
and somebody in the class
raises their hand again and says,
"Can you value a Netflix subscriber?"
Notice the question, not can you value
Netflix the company, can you value a
Netflix subscriber?
So Ashima, you're going to be my Netflix
subscriber evaluation. Let's take this
to the to value Netflix subscriber.
What's the first thing I need to
estimate?
How much
I'm going to pay?
That's the easy part, right? So, are you
a Netflix subscriber? How much do you
pay per month?
It's so indirectly goes through your
cell phone or in our undergraduate
class, everybody put their hands up for
the saying I have a Netflix
subscription, but they're all in the
family subscription. I well know the
feeling because I carry five family
members on my subscription, too.
Actually six, I'm not counting my wife
here, but we're a team, but the other
four. On any given day, I can turn
Netflix on and it says, "You can't watch
it." I say, "Why not?" Somebody's
watching it already.
Where? Then I have to start texting,
"Get off Netflix now. I need to be on
Netflix."
But it's a subscription model.
Pretty predictable, right?
In terms of revenues.
Because the subscription is the is It
will change because there's a they
Netflix obviously raises prices, you can
bring that in. But before I do all of
that, I have to make a judgment on how
long a Netflix subscriber will stay a
Netflix subscriber.
You say, "That's a complete guess." Not
really, right?
What is the statistic you will find in
these platform companies that you can
use to estimate
how long a subscriber stays a
subscriber?
It's called a churn rate. Do you know
what a churn rate is? It's a percent It
essentially captures what percentage of
your subscribers renew.
You know what that number looks like for
Netflix?
It's 95%.
A 95% renewal rate translates to about a
12, maybe 13-year life.
We can debate why it's so high. That's
entirely part of the business model.
Maybe the Stranger Things next season is
enough to keep you on or something else,
but you can see how these shows work in
terms of keeping you on.
So, you have 12-year life, I estimate
the subscription revenues. I'm almost
there, but there are expenses that
Netflix faces faces to service each
subscriber. Not a whole lot.
But you subtract out those costs, you
come up with the profits I'm going to
make per subscriber, which are very
close to cash flows because there's
nothing to depreciate, etc.
And I come up
with a present value.
Of course, I've got to make judgment on
how are these cash flows? And you could
argue that existing subscriber revenues
are pretty predictable, so I'm going to
use a lower cost of capital. You can do
a dance and get there, but
ultimately, that's what I did in class.
I ended up with about $500
per US Netflix subscriber.
I'm not being parochial here.
The reason I do that
is how much you pay for Netflix varies
depending on where in the world you are
in.
How many of you are are India-based or
are from India?
If you look at a Netflix subscription in
India,
there's actually a version of Netflix
you can get, I think, for $4 a month,
but you can watch it only on a
smartphone.
Which is fine, because for some Indians,
that's the only device that's connected
to the internet
or to cell service.
You see why this matters, right? One of
the things I find surprising when I when
Netflix has an analyst meeting
is when you know, the the leading point
always is, "Look at how many new
subscribers we had." And I'm waiting for
the question. I still haven't heard it
asked, which is, "If you're the analyst
sitting in that room and says Netflix
says, 'We've added 8 million subscribers
last year,' what's a logical question
you're going to ask them?"
"Where in the world are these
subscribers coming from?" Why? Cuz the
average Indian Netflix subscriber is
worth about 1/5 the value of a US
subscriber, because they pay less in
subscription revenues. There are more of
them. That's a good good side, so you
can get Tell me the growth story, but
I've got to bring in the fact that
they're worth less.
I would never have thought about those
nuances
if I hadn't tried to answer the
question. And after I valued the Netflix
subscription subscriber, I said, "This
is neat."
Why waste this architect? Let's value a
Spotify subscriber. That should be very
similar, right? So, I estimated the life
of a Spotify subscriber. Again, pretty
high renewal, right?
And then I got to the course, and I
started thinking about business models.
You know how the Netflix business model
works, right? You make lots of content,
and then you seek out subscribers.
You know how Spotify pays for content?
For free.
Okay. Do you have Spotify?
Do you have Spotify?
Who's your favorite?
So, you
you can make up somebody if you're too
embarrassed to to admit who it is,
right? You can say Taylor Swift. That
usually kind of works, right?
Let's say you're a subscriber. You like
Taylor Swift. My granddaughter loves
Taylor Swift. That's all she listens to
all day. I think she listens to the same
song all day.
You know, every time she listens to
Taylor Swift, Taylor Swift gets paid for
that stream.
Yeah.
0.003, but think about the number of
streams, right? The fact that it's
small, you know, you multiply 0.003 by
100 million, that's a lot of money. And
Taylor Swift is not poverty-stricken as
a consequence,
but you see from a business model what
this does, right? It means that there's
a variable cost now with Spotify that it
not have, which means a subscriber to
Spotify is worth less, even if they
charge the same subscription fee,
than a subscriber to Netflix. It's a
different business model.
So, if you're valuing Spotify, and I see
40%
margins, I'm going to push back. The
reason being, right now the cost of the
music is about 83%
to 84% of the revenues, and it's not
budgeted as they scale up.
But I wouldn't have thought about that
until until I started drinking. And
since I was on this on this trip, I
said, "Hey, a valued Netflix subscriber,
Spotify subscriber, what's the value of
an Amazon Prime member to Amazon?"
How many of you have Amazon Prime?
Okay.
So, Sushmita, tell me how this works.
You're an Amazon How long have you been
on Amazon Prime?
Yeah. I've been there since 2004. I was
one of the originals. They don't give me
a break because of it.
And I wait how many of you canceled your
Amazon Prime?
Oh, that's unusual. Right? What did you
What led you to cancel it? Did you not
like Jeff Bezos in speedos or
Yeah.
It's actually moving from India to US.
Okay. So, it it was a forced
cancellation. My guess is they'll get
you back as a different kind of Prime
member.
The The reality is once you get Prime,
you're hooked.
And hooked on multiple levels.
So, first, if you're Amazon, you sign a
Prime member, you got a long-life sub-
subscriber to Prime. How do you make
money of that subscription?
You charge 139 a year. And I'll tell you
if that's all they did, this is a
money-losing proposition for Amazon.
Here's why. In return for the Prime,
France, what do you get in return for
paying for Prime?
Uh free shipment.
Free shipping.
And
And last year, they actually are
explicit about how much they spend on
free shipping. It's tens of billions of
dollars, including, you know, So, you
get free shipping. You also get free
entertainment through Amazon Prime. You
also get a 10% discount. I know all the
insides of Amazon Prime. I live in that
space. I get a 10% discount when I go to
Whole Foods.
And if I don't like what I get, I just
take it to my local UPS. I don't even
have to put in a package.
They have this nice code. They scan it.
I'm money back. So, they give away a lot
of stuff, and it actually is well in
excess of 139. So, if I stopped right
there, which is where I initially did, I
said, "This makes no sense. Why would
they do it?"
You know why they get a benefit from
Prime?
You know, the typical Prime member
spends three times more on Amazon
than a non-Prime member.
That incremental revenue and earnings,
if you bring that in, makes an Amazon
Prime member
a value-adding proposition. You multiply
it by 200 million Prime members, Amazon
Prime alone is probably worth 200
billion to 300 billion dollars. Just the
Prime.
All of that from that initial question
of can we value a Netflix subscriber?
And then we get to 2020.
And I was teaching my valuation class
down in Paulson. I convinced them this
year, I don't like Paulson. Can we
please do it in a different room? So,
I'm glad they moved me here.
It was March 6th of 2020.
Teaching a class.
And you know how we get this message
that kind of is like a immediate
message. Everybody's phones go off at
the same time. We all get a message from
the university at exactly the same time.
You know what the message said, right?
There's a virus floating around. We have
no idea what it's a called the
coronavirus. We have no idea what
what it does.
But
we know spring break is a week away, but
we're going to let you go home. Let you
is kind of a kind way of saying you have
to go home now. But don't worry, we'll
be back in 3 weeks. Complete lie, but we
all went home. And the rest of that
semester was taught from my
upstairs office in the in my home in La
Jolla. It was actually a lot of fun. Sun
was out, so I could watch the ocean. But
I was teaching the class in Zoom. And
there was a problem. One is that
everybody in this class, and I'll let
you in, has to pick a company to value.
In that class, people had to pick a
company to value. And on March 6th, not
only were we sent home, but the entire
global economy came to a grinding halt.
I still remember again, this was in
Zoom session.
Student says, you told us to pick a
company and I picked Boeing to value and
I am deeply troubled.
You know why, right? March 21st, 2020
Boeing was going to sell aircraft,
right? To whom? Airlines. Airlines are
not even getting off the ground. So,
your business So, this is completely
independent of what other hash that
Boeing has made with their business
model.
This is the entire shutdown.
In addition, Boeing had borrowed money
and it was heading towards a cliff.
The new stories of Boeing wouldn't make
it, so I Should I pick a different
company? I said, "No, let's see what we
can do." So, March 23rd, 2020, I
actually valued Boeing in class. The
YouTube video is floating around
somewhere where I said, "Just because a
company shut down doesn't mean you can't
you shouldn't you know you you can stop
trying to estimate value because you
still have to trade."
Interesting exercise. How do you value a
company when the global economy is shut
down and you have no idea what's coming?
Immense amounts of uncertainty.
But, I learned interesting things about
valuation in the face of macro
uncertainty, economic shutdowns.
So, I think Deep Seek
I lost I mean I bought in video in 2018.
I halved it 2 years ago. I halved it
again, but I still have a quarter of it
left and I'll feel the pain this evening
when I check out my final portfolio.
But, the plus
is this is going to be a learning
moment. This is going to be interesting
from a valuation exercise to say, "How
does this play out? Where does it play
out? Where does it end?"
Everything I know about valuation I've
learned in the course of teaching this
class. So, one of the things I'm going
to try to do over the next 15 weeks
is not tell you how to do things because
that's kind of useless.
Is to take you through the process of
how you answer these questions that are
going to come up in the next 15 weeks
that we don't have an answer to right
now.
Now, to give you a window into that
process because at the end I want you to
take that process away where if you're
asked a question to which you don't know
the answer, you don't say I don't know
or say let's look it up online, you
actually try to reason your way to an
answer.
So longly then, let me talk a little bit
about the logistics of the class. You
know, my office is right upstairs in
this building. As you know, this is a
very very convoluted structure with
three different buildings, Shimkin, now
Kaufman and Tisch all gathered together.
So you get on the wrong elevator, God
help you. You will never get to the
floor you want, which you probably found
out already, but you're
experienced enough with the elevator
system at Stern that you're ready for an
MBA. So now you you can find me.
I am also, you know, on I mean I I'm
pretty good about responding to my
emails. I get about 500 a day, so I've
got to be careful to keep it in control
because I go 10 days without answering,
I'm dead. I'm drowned. But I try to stay
ahead of the game at least for these 15
weeks.
My homepage we'll come back and talk
about much of what happens in this
class. You will use your evaluation is
on there.
My office hours basically will be before
class.
But those of you in my corporate finance
class will remember the fair game
principle. Do you remember what the fair
game principle is?
Michael, what is my fair game principle?
I remember.
If you find me
unfair game.
Well, I'll give you two exceptions, but
barring those two exceptions two
exceptions are the restroom.
Partly because it's unfair, right?
Because one half of you can find me
there or roughly a half.
And the other is on if I ever catch me
at a gym or something, don't ask me
because my heart rate might be too high
to give you a sensible response. But if
you find me, you So I try to So the game
starts right now, which means for the
rest of the semester what I'm going to
try to do is make it difficult for you
to find me.
Like what I always take the stairs,
because I know you guys never do.
Right? You take the elevators, so I'll
try to avoid it. I walk the stairs. So,
if you want to find me, take the stairs.
You'll catch me there. And you can ask
me whatever question you want.
I won't go far enough to say if you find
me on a social media site, ask me,
because I generally don't engage on
Twitter or Facebook or anything. I I
repost, but I don't engage. So, if you
have a question, find me.
I'm fair game, right?
There are two TAs. Justin was just here
at the start of the class with me. They
both went through this class last year,
so they are intimately aware of the
tortures I will put you through, so take
advantage. I'll tell you. They will have
review sessions every week starting next
week. And the review sessions,
basically, they would take problems from
past quizzes and exams and work them
through, because I won't do that in
class. That's not the best use of my
time.
But they will work through it. So, if
you have mechanical trouble in terms of
converting concepts to practice, well
worth going to the review sessions.
Okay?
So, here's what I'd like to start with
today. I want to lay out some very broad
themes about valuation. And while I
won't talk about a single number, no
betas, cost of capital, cash flow, to
me, the next 20 minutes might be the the
20 minutes that you remember the most
and matter the most in your class.
Here are broad themes. First,
if you ask me to characterize valuation
as a discipline, a reminder question I
get asked all the time.
Is valuation a science
or not?
Don't jump in too soon, right? Let's dig
a little deeper, right? Meenakshi, is
valuation a science?
Okay, that's tough to answer. Is Is
mathematics a science?
It's the only pure science. In fact,
mathematicians are convinced that the
rest of us are impostors.
So, let's dig a little little deeper.
Dagmar, what is it about mathematics
that makes it a science?
All kinds of numbers into it.
I can plug all kinds of numbers into
evaluation and come up with another
number. It's more than that, right? You
plug some numbers and you get an answer.
It's absolute, right? I don't want to
insult you, but what's 2 + 3?
Five, right? Left hand, right hand,
calculator, computer, AI, ChatGPT, North
Pole, South Pole, doesn't matter where
you are. It's not maybe five, could be
five, it is five. And if I give you any
other answer, I screwed up.
Science, you get the inputs right,
you get the output right.
Conversely, you get the output wrong,
you did something wrong.
So mathematics is clearly a science.
Physics is mostly a science, right?
We all found a way to get to the ninth
floor, which we can,
get the windows open, which I don't
think we can, but let's say we could,
and we all jumped out.
We don't fall in the order of our IQs or
where we are in the corporate hierarchy
or how much we know about valuation. The
laws of gravity are the laws of gravity.
Physics is mostly a science. There are
portions of physics you can say they're
they're making up crap.
Now, they every discipline does that.
Mostly a science. But the essence of a
science, you get the inputs right,
you're going to get the output right.
Is there any chance
that evaluation
could be a science?
Absolutely no chance.
Right?
I'm going to value Nvidia again this
week. This is the right time to do it
when everybody's running for the exit
doors and everybody's terrified,
uncertainty is greatest. I'm going to
try my best.
I'm going to take everything I know
about valuation, which is not everything
that it can be known, but I
accumulated a fair amount of knowledge.
Take every piece of data I can find
on AI, AI chips, deep seek,
and I'm going to try to come up with the
value of Nvidia.
Let's say I come up with that value.
What percentage of the time am I going
to be right?
In the sense that numbers that I use are
actually going to get delivered.
0% of the time. Why?
Cuz life gets in the way, right? I'm
forecasting the future. There are lots
of things I don't anticipate that will
happen
that were unanticipatable
at the start, if that's even a word that
can be used.
I'm going to be wrong 100% of the time.
Before you start digging philos, why is
that? There's a simple reason for that.
I'm not God.
If you're operating under the delusion,
you have far deeper problems than I can
solve in this room.
But you are forecasting the future,
you're going to be wrong 100% of the
time.
Valuation is not a science, it'll never
be a science, and the sooner we come to
that acceptance, the healthier the
discussion of valuation will become.
I have some terrible things to say about
accounting, and especially about fair
value accounting. And the reason is
accountants actually operate under this
misconception that valuation is a
science, and they think if they write
more rules, it'll become more
scientific. That everybody does the same
stupid thing,
and you can force them all,
that the process has become scientific.
That's a very strange definition of
science.
It's not a science. So, it must be an
art, right? So, let's take that apart.
I think on the third or fourth floor of
this building, you come off the
elevator, there's a Picasso hanging on
the wall. Don't get too excited. It's a,
you know, picture of a Picasso, not a
Picasso.
Which reminded me of when I took my
older son, who's now 35, when he was 8
years old, I took him to the Met for a
Picasso exhibit.
You know how long 8-year-olds last in
museums?
Not very long.
With immense amounts of bribery, I said,
"I'll take you to the baseball card
store. You can get the ice cream of your
choice."
He finally relented. We went in. He
lasted about 30 minutes.
He come out and said, "Ryan, what did
you think of that?" He said, "Dad, I was
not impressed."
I said, "What? That is a Picasso
exhibit." He said, "This guy can't get
the nose in the right place."
You notice about Picasso's nose coming
out of the side of the head, the top of
the head, the back of the head. It's
almost like he was either drugged or
drunk, which given Picasso's history,
it's probably both.
But for whatever reason, we've gathered
together and Picasso's a special $200
million. Thank God my son is not the
appraiser.
Cuz then he'd be giving Picassos away.
This guy can't get the nose in the right
place.
The essence of an art is you really
cannot teach it.
Say, "But I can go to Juilliard, or I
can go to" You're right, you can teach
them the the mechanics, or you I can
teach you to paint like an
impressionist.
But you can do everything that Picasso
did, but you won't be Picasso because
there's this magical component that
makes you great.
I hope valuation is not an art, or a
wasted 40 years of my life trying to
teach something that cannot be taught.
It's not a science. It's not an art.
What the heck is it? The word I use to
describe valuation is it's a craft.
I'll give you the discipline and that I
think is closest to valuation.
It's cooking.
Think of how you master cooking.
I'll give you one strategy. You can
watch the Food Network 16 hours a day,
every day.
My daughter used to do this when she was
younger, when now she
She could tell you in theory how to make
a soufflé. She couldn't cook a lick.
You don't learn cooking by watching the
Food Network. You don't learn cooking by
watching Beat Bobby Flay. You don't
learn cooking by reading cookbooks. You
learn cooking by
cooking.
You got to go to that room in your
apartment that you call the kitchen.
I know you've been avoiding it like the
plague.
Cuz you got DoorDash. Why would you ever
need to go to that room?
And when you first start cooking, what
happens? Fire alarms go off.
Disaster strikes. I still remember the
first time I scrambled eggs.
Nobody told me I was supposed to spray
the damn pan.
I scrambled the eggs. They looked really
good, but they stuck to the pan. Pan and
eggs go into the trash, but I learned a
very important lesson about
scrambling eggs. First, spray the pan.
You learn cooking
by cooking.
You learn valuation
by doing
Which means the 26 sessions you're going
to spend in this classroom are kind of
wasted, right?
You're going to watch me talk about
valuation.
But to learn valuation, you got to do
it. So, I'm going to drag you across
that finish line
partly by force. Your project will be to
pick a company and value it because And
it's a real company. No XYZ widget
company. No case studies. That's
ridiculous to have case studies in the
valuation class when you got 40,000 live
case studies out there.
Pick one of them.
Value the company. And if you really,
really want to master valuation, I'm
going to give you a second shot.
Every week, I'm going to put up what I
call a valuation of the week.
So, tomorrow
will be the first valuation of the week.
You know what I'm going to do? I'm going
to value the S&P 500.
Let's start big, right? Cuz the big
question is, is the market overvalued?
So, I'm going to give you my valuation
with my story for the S&P 500. I
emphasize the word my, and I'll back it
up. There's a blog post that goes with
the next Excel spreadsheet. I will do
the dirty work of building the
spreadsheet, and all you have to do is
take that valuation
and look at places where you disagree
with me.
I'll do the work of converting that into
a value. There'll be a Google shared
spreadsheet where I'll have in the first
line my value, my estimates, and I want
you to go into that Google shared
spreadsheet and take It'll take you all
of 5 minutes to do. This is not deep
You're not building a spreadsheet from
scratch.
I'll tell you up front what you're going
to say. You're going to say, "Look, we
just started the class. I've never
valued an index or even a company."
So, I understand first week, you know
what you're going to do. You're going to
take every number in that spreadsheet,
leave it as is, take the risk-free rate,
add a third decimal to it,
and your value's going to be very close
to mine.
First week, we're all going to come in
values right on top of mine because, you
know, the way I know this class is
working is next week I'm going to put up
a Maybe it'll be in Vinamilk. The week
after that, maybe Vinamilk, which is a
Vietnamese dairy company. You're saying,
"Why are you going to Vietnam and
picking a dairy company?" If all you
cook is pasta and day in day out, you're
going to get really good at cooking
pasta, right?
But then I say, "If you Can you make
some bibimbap for me?" You're going to
say, "What the heck is a bibimbap? I
can't do that." If you really want to
understand valuation, you got to try
different kinds of companies. So, over
the next 14 weeks, there's going to be a
valuation of the week each week. It's
completely optional.
You're going to do fine on this class
without ever doing a valuation of the
week, but there's a difference between
doing well in this class and really
learning valuation.
It's too much to ask of yourself to do
all 14.
So, pick your battles. Pick the
companies you find interesting.
Maybe Vinamilk is a company you want to
take on.
Do at least three or four of them
because this is the process, and don't
stop after this class is done.
Keep adding companies. Every time you
value company, you will learn something
new about valuation.
And the essence of a craft
is you never ever master it.
There's always some aspect that's a No,
Gordon Ramsay might be a master chef,
but there are cuisines he's not very
good at, right?
Which effectively means you can never
shut the door and say, "Look, I've
mastered the craft." Leave the door
ajar.
There are things that you can continue
to learn about the craft.
Second,
you're going to get sick and tired
of a pushback you're going to hear from
me. And here's what the pushback will
look like. You'll say, "So-and-so valued
the company." Or can you value this
company? And my first question to you
is, do you want me to value this company
or price it? Sounds like I'm playing
with words, right?
But in this class, we're going to draw a
distinction in valuing something and
pricing that same thing.
And here's the distinction. We know what
drives value. It's cash flows, growth,
and risk.
And you can build a discounted cash flow
model if you need to to bring them all
in.
So, when you do discounted cash flow
valuation, actually mean what you say
when you say I want to do it, you are
trying to value something.
You're saying, "What about price? It
comes from demand and supply, right?
What drives demand and supply? It's
true, cash flows, growth, and risk might
affect it, but so do mood
and momentum and even revenge."
Saying revenge?
Heard the GameStop story?
Some of you might be old enough to
remember what GameStop used to be,
right? It used to be a staple at every
mall.
And there was a time when if you were a
teenager, this is the store you went to
because you played with the different
games, and once in a while you had
enough money to actually buy a game.
But those days are done.
I don't remember the last time I was
actually in a physical mall.
GameStop has faded as a and by 2020
that or 2021 I think the price was down
to like $12 per share. It was heading
towards the exit door.
But something magical happened.
A group of people got got together on
Reddit.
We can't keep social media with the No,
this is part of investing in markets
called Wall Street Bets. That was the
Reddit group.
And they decided that they were going to
push up the price of GameStop. So I
actually
made the mistake of going on that Reddit
group to see what rationale they could
give for why a fading business model
like GameStop would come back.
And I read through like thousand
comments. Not one of them talked about
business models or why Do you know what
the overriding reason they were pushing
the price up was? What were they trying
to accomplish?
Take revenge on the hedge funds. And
that's an entirely different debate we
can have as why they're so pissed off at
hedge funds. You know, but clearly they
were. The way they were going to take
revenge is they took the $12 and they
bid the stock price up to $400 per
share. You know, with small lightly
traded stocks enough people gather
together
it can happen.
Revenge.
You think that doesn't make sense?
Come on. What's a more authentic human
emotion?
Revenge or working through a DCF
spreadsheet?
You hate your neighbor. You're not
working through a DCF spreadsheet.
You're thinking about keying his car or
breaking into his garage or doing
something that you kind of restrain
yourself from doing. Revenge
is
part of humanity.
Mood and momentum.
You see, what mood?
What is the mood around AI until Friday?
AI is amazing.
It'll be amazing how quickly the mood
can shift in the entire opposite
direction, right?
Mood and momentum.
Here's the difference between valuing
something and pricing something. You ask
me to value something, I've got to
understand the business model, estimate
cash flows, growth, and risk, and bring
it into value. You ask me to price
something,
I'm going to look for other things like
it out there, look at what people are
paying for those other things, and say
this is what I would pay for yours. A
very different process.
The next time you see an equity research
analyst say they valued a company using
price-earnings ratios and 20 other
companies,
a peer group.
Before they get deeper, say, "Look, you
haven't valued the company, you priced
it." There's nothing I'm not making a
judgment that this is good or bad, it's
just different.
Most of you, if you end up in this
process, will have pricing jobs.
You go to work for a bank, I don't even
know why banks waste their time on
discounted cash flow models.
They're in the pricing game. They've got
to get deals done.
The reality is many of you are taking
this class because you think you will
have valuation job, but you'll have
pricing job. So, it's my
responsibility to talk about how to
price things better, because we don't do
a very good job pricing things.
Now, SeatGeek does a better job of
pricing Yankee tickets than an equity
research analyst does in pricing
Microsoft. We'll talk about what it is
we're missing in the pricing process,
but this is something we're going to
come back to over and over again.
Today,
Microsoft's value didn't drop by 800
billion, its price dropped by 800
billion.
Why am I valuing Amazon uh
I'm sorry, Nvidia's value didn't drop by
price value didn't drop by 800, it's
price dropped by 800 billion. The reason
I'm valuing Nvidia is what's the
question I'm trying to answer?
Is did the value also drop? We all agree
that today Nvidia is a less valuable
company than on Friday, cuz we don't
need those high value high chips at
least for some aspects of VR.
The question is, how much did the value
drop? If it dropped by only 600 billion,
the price dropped by 800 billion.
We're in business here. We can talk
about buying Nvidia.
You're asking a different question,
framing it differently, but that comes
from asking different questions.
Now, if I asked you what your priors
were about what we'd value,
most people say you value companies like
Nvidia and Apple, but the truth is this
is a
class about valuing just about anything.
True, we're going to value publicly
traded companies across the life cycle.
We're going to value everything from
Palantir,
which is, I don't know, does I don't
even know what it does. It does
mysterious things to the CIA and the
FBI, and I'm afraid to ask Danny, are
you from one of you from Palantir? So,
don't ask him too many questions. You
might end up in Guantanamo Bay.
Right?
But,
it's a young company with lots of
potential and clearly some competitive
advantages.
All the way to craft kinds of Coca-Cola
or worse, right? Across the life cycle,
young to old.
If all I'm valuing is mature companies,
this class would be a waste of time
cuz a machine could do it.
We're also going to value private
businesses. Let's face it, for every
public company that needs evaluation,
there are lots and lots of private
businesses, and the way private
companies are valued
is really an art form. The kinds of
corners that get cut.
We're going to talk about how we can
think about valuing private companies
and not cut corners and come up with a
We're going to also talk about valuing
individual assets.
I'm a Yankee fan, and I'm
deadly curious
is Juan Soto really worth
745, 765 million? I'm taking off 20
million there.
To the New York Mets. We can value an
additional player, right?
In fact, in some cases, a person can
make a difference. I think Shohei Ohtani
has made the Dodgers a more valuable
thing. Not because they won the World
Series.
That fifth inning in the fifth game will
stay in my mind forever as a Yankee fan,
but I don't want to revisit that bad
memory. In what way did Ohtani increase
the value of the Dodgers? First, how
much did the Dodgers
pay Ohtani on his contract?
Give me the answer. 700 million is what
It really is only about 450 million.
Why?
It's the most absurdly structured
contract I've ever seen.
It's 20 million over the next 10 years.
See, that's not a lot of money. 2
million a year, I can live on that.
Plus 680 million at the end, right? So,
if you think about value, taking
present, 450 million. What does he bring
to the Yankees?
What is What drives the value of a
sports franchise?
Tickets used to be the key driver. Those
days are done. About 15% value comes
from Merchandise is another 10%, but
you're missing the big 75%.
It's media contracts.
You're saying, "Why would signing Ohtani
affect that?"
You've now got an entire country as your
extension for your market. I'll wager
when the Dodgers are playing, there are
a lot more Japanese watching that game
than people in LA.
Lionel Messi increased the value of
every major league soccer team by about
15% when he signed for my with Miami a
couple of years ago.
Why? Because he drew in people who would
never watch soccer, at least the soccer
played in the US because Messi was on
the field.
Because he drew people into stadiums, he
You know, Apple TV, which had the sole
rights to MLS, saw its subscriber
numbers jump.
So, can we value what Juan Soto brings
to the Mets? Yes.
But I don't think it had anything to do
with value. Why did the Mets pay
Soto 765 million dollars? Think pricing.
Because the Dodgers on the face of it
paid 700 million. This is how the
pricing game works, right? If you're
Scott Boras, you go, "Hey, they paid 700
million. You got to pay that um the
Nobody talks in present value terms in
this process."
Maybe we should.
But they paid seven I wager if Soto had
come up
without the Otani contract, he'd be
talking 500 million.
It's a pricing game.
So, we're going to talk about pricing
and valuing. We might even ask is
Bitcoin
under or over priced. You can't ask it's
under or over valued. Why not?
It has no cash flows. It's not a cash
It's If it's a currency, you can ask is
it a good currency? If it's a
collectible, then
you know, so the everything is fair game
in this class, right? So, if you have
something unique you think you want to
be see valued or priced, we'll talk
about at least the process to do it.
We'll also talk about looking at value
from different perspectives. Like what?
We're going to first value companies as
investors.
But as investors, you have little
control over how companies are run. You
essentially have to take them as given,
right? So, you might not like the way
Mark Zuckerberg runs
Facebook, but what what the heck are you
going to do about it? He controls 57% of
the voting rights. We're also going to
value companies from the inside out.
What does that mean? If you are a family
controlled business, you say, "How do I
increase the value of the business?" Or
if you're a consultant telling a
company, you now have the levers under
your control. You can change the way the
company's run.
So, we're going to look at companies
from different perspectives. Same
principles apply, but the levers start
to become more movable in some other
than
We're also going to bring in a little
bit of option pricing. We'll talk about
We're not to value options. There's an
entire class for that, but to value
things in businesses that have
optionality.
I'll sit at the table. You're buying
your valuing an oil company. Its
reserves are all I mean, it's extensive
reserves, but they're very expensive to
get out of the ground. In fact, they're
so expensive that right now the cost of
getting the oil out of the ground
exceeds oil price.
Remember in 2020 the oil price dropped
like $30 a barrel?
2/3 of the oil companies in the world,
their oil reserves
were not viable.
So, if I came to you with an oil company
in the middle of 2020 and you said, "How
much would you pay for it?" From an
intrinsic value standpoint, you might
have looked at the value of price of oil
and said, "Why would I pay for it?"
Why would I pay for it, though?
There's an optionality. What's the
optionality? Oil price at $30, but we
know the history of oil prices. They can
go up, they can go down, and if they go
up, these reserves could become viable.
It's a different way of looking at
companies, and we'll talk about how
These are called real options.
We talked about the Facebook platform. 3
billion people on it, right? Right now,
how does Facebook make money?
Almost entirely advertising.
But you got 3 billion people an hour
every day. Could there be other stuff
you could do with them?
I'm not going to fall into the metaverse
hole because that you can never get out
of it, but there are other things they
could conceivably do, right? Which right
now I don't have in my valuation because
they don't even know whether it's
economic, but to the extent that they
can,
that's an optionality there.
So, we're going to look at almost every
aspect of it.
Which brings me to my fourth theme, and
this is something that I had to learn
myself as I taught this class.
About 5 years into teaching this class,
I had an existential crisis.
So, why am I put on the face of the
earth? What am I doing? I mean, that's
too deep. That's not how far I went.
But, I said, "Why am I teaching this
class?" And the reason I was in crisis
is because
I could value mechanically just about
anything, but I no faith. Strange word
to use, right?
Faith to do what? To act on my
valuations.
Because I knew how easily I could move
the numbers around.
And I said, "What am I missing?"
And I realized what I was missing is
value doesn't come from a spreadsheet,
it comes from a business model. I didn't
flesh out the story that drove my
numbers.
And to be honest, it didn't come easily
to me, storytelling.
But, I did teach myself enough
storytelling to be able to have faith in
my valuations. That started in the
1990s. In fact, in 2017,
it became a book because I was terrified
of what was happening to valuation in
practice.
Those of you work in valuation,
it's really become financial modeling,
right?
I mean, you take the training the
street. I don't know. I have nothing bad
to say about these people because they
do provide a service.
They're Excel ninjas.
They say, "If you hit these buttons
together, every alternate row becomes a
different color. Amazing. That will give
me a much better value for the company,
right?"
But, essentially, that's what it's
become, financial modeling. And along
the way, we completely lost our way on
valuation.
A good valuation
can never be numbers in a spreadsheet. A
good valuation is a bridge between
stories and numbers.
What does that mean? When you show me
the valuation of a company,
and you look at my numbers, let's say
you see revenues of 50 billion in year
10, you say,
"Why are your 50 billion year 10?"
Here's the answer you don't want to
hear. It's because I used a 25% growth
rate for the next 5 years and 8%
thereafter. What the heck do you do with
that?
What I have to tell you is my story for
the company that will allow it to
deliver 50 billion in revenues.
Every number in your evaluation has to
have a story that goes with it. And
every story you tell me about a company
has to have a number attached to it.
Like what? You tell me your company has
a great brand name. I don't even know
what that means. How does it translate?
Where does it show up? You have you know
you have a great management team.
What is it? You have a loyal employee
force. Where does it show up?
Every story you tell about your company
has to have a number attached to it. And
one of my challenges to you over the
next 15
weeks is there's lots of fuzzy stuff,
what they call soft stuff, and people
kind of leave it to the side. I want you
to think about every soft thing you hear
about in every other class I how would I
convert you make your pain in the neck
in those classes, but that's not my
problem.
So, people use a word like
sustainability.
What exactly does that mean? What are
you sustaining?
Why do people care? Where does it show
up?
It's I think good for both the
sustainability people and you to ask
those questions, right? Because we've
let them get away with a lot of
for a while,
and it's time to start pushing back. You
want to talk about sustainability, I'm
willing to talk. You want to talk about
ESG, I have terrible things to say, but
I'll push back. Everything you bring to
the table, my job is to say what's
behind it.
You say that's so mercenary. You're
running a business.
Of course it's going to be mercenary. It
has to show up in the numbers, right?
You can't take customer loyalty and pay
dividends with customer loyalty. The
customer loyalty has to show up
somewhere. Repeat purchases, higher
margins.
Because I had to teach myself
storytelling and connecting,
I go through a process,
a linear process. You know why a linear
process? Because I'm a natural number
cruncher.
I need steps.
If you're a natural storyteller, and
that's the question I'm going to come
back and ask you to think about what
comes more easily to you, storytelling
or number crunching.
If you're a natural storyteller, you
might not like sequences. It throws you
off. Come up with your No, so we'll go
through the process by which I connect
stories and numbers, not because my
sequence is right for you, but I want
you to think about the sequence you're
going to use to bring
both halves of your brain to play in the
evaluation.
And finally, let's build on this word
freak.
I don't do consulting. I've never
appraised a company for money, and I'm
not doing this is saying this for I'm
just I'm too lazy and too opinionated to
do it.
So, when I value companies, I have an
audience of one,
which is myself. The only person I have
to keep happy is me, and luckily, I like
what I do, so I keep myself pretty
happy.
But I don't value companies because I'm
intellectually curious. I don't lie
awake at nights and wonder what's going
to happen what the value in videos right
now.
Maybe you do, but I think of a serial
serious mental illness if that's what
you do.
I value companies because I want to act
on those valuations, and it's a lot more
difficult than it sounds, right?
Think through what has to happen for you
to act on a valuation. First, you have
to value it, right? Did you have to make
a lot of assumptions to get there?
Absolutely.
Do you have enough faith in the
valuation when you first value a
company? Probably not, right? Because
you say, "I don't know. I just made up
stuff. I came out of that book or that
lecture."
No, but that's the process. At some
point, maybe you'll acquire enough
faith. You value a company, you have
enough faith. Doesn't mean you're
certain about the number, but you I
think I'm it's going to be somewhere
around there.
But there's another thing you need to
have faith in to actually make money,
right? Which is let's say you value
company at 100 and you feel pretty
comfortable if stock is trading at 60,
what has to happen for you to make
money?
60 has to go to 100. The price has to
correct to value and you have to faith
that we're all believers in efficient
markets.
The only thing is when it happens,
right? So don't beat up efficient
markets too badly because markets are
truly random
or completely
lost.
We have to have faith in our value and
faith that the price will correct.
You're saying, "How do I get that
faith?" I don't know.
All I can do is tell you where my faith
comes from.
And I'll be honest because
when
you have faith, that faith is going to
be tested.
What does that mean?
If I think a company's undervalued and I
buy the stock, you know how my faith
gets tested? The next day the stock
drops another 10%. That's the market
saying to you saying, "Do you still have
faith about right now?" And let's face
it, at some point you say, "I give up."
And when that happens, I often write
about it in my blog saying, "I give up."
In fact, when I sold Vale in 2014, the
Brazilian mining company,
the title of the the the the title I
gave my post was no mas no mas,
which comes from an old boxing match for
Roberto Duran,
you know. And the big response from
Brazil was we speak Portuguese, not
Spanish, but they missed the message,
which is I give up, I give up, you know.
So the essence of faith is it will get
tested and sometimes it will break and
there's no shame in that.
You know why I don't like to go to
Omaha, Nebraska around April or May of
each year?
Because you have what I call investing
Woodstock that happens there, which is
people are true believers show up in
Omaha value investors and they pay
homage to to what used to be two 90-plus
year-olds. now it's going to be only
one.
But there's the sense of absolutism
there, which is where the chosen ones we
do the right things, cuts against every
grain of how I think about valuation.
I still remember a talk that Mother
Teresa once
gave. This was in the '70s. I was lucky
enough to
And she started her talk by saying,
"Every morning I wake up and I question
the existence of God."
If Mother Teresa can get up every
morning and question the existence of
God, I can get up every morning and say,
"Did I get the Nvidia value right?" And
this is a much lower level question,
right? So, when people say, "I'm
absolutely sure about value." I say,
"Where does that certainty come from?"
So, remember those themes because those
are going to underlie this class. So,
the the structure of the class, you can
see is, you know, we're going to spend
about
maybe eight sessions
getting the basics nailed down. You're
going to get impatient because we're not
going to value a single company. If you
don't know what free cash flow to the
firm is, or you don't know how to bring
risk We we can't get to valuing
companies.
So, we're going to spend some time get
And in the process, if you've taken
corporate finance, you're going to see
me revisiting things like free cash flow
to equity.
You remember free cash flow to equity?
Vaguely, right? And that's the problem
is it's vague. So, I'm going to revisit
it and I'm going to build on it. So, and
then we're going to hit the ground
running. We're going to value companies
in as many different companies as we
can.
Once we value companies, we're going to
turn to pricing. We're going to spend a
few sessions on how to do pricing right.
What's missing in pricing right now?
What can we do better?
Almost all in built-in statistics. Using
more data, using it more sensibly.
Once we get through the pricing,
we'll spend a a session on valuing
private businesses. You see in just a
session,
if you can value a public company, I'm
going to argue that you already have the
levers in place. I have to tell you
which levers to move differently to
value private businesses.
Then I'm going to turn to options, and
I'll start by spending about 30 minutes
with basic option pricing because I will
not make the mistake of assuming that
you actually are familiar with a
Black-Scholes model.
You might be familiar in a very loose
sense of the word. You saw it, but it's
past your mind already. So, I'll spend
about 30 minutes kind of giving you a
very quick because I need the option
pricing model to be able to value
startups and young farmer companies. I'm
going to value real options.
Then in session 24 and 25, I'm going to
circle back to first valuing
acquisitions. What's separate different
about valuing a target company in
acquisition? Two words that come up,
control and synergy. We're going to talk
about, hey, what do they mean? How do
they How do we put a number on it?
And then I want to talk a little bit
about value enhancement. Now, how do you
change the value of a company?
Why? Because that might be your job. You
own a business, you want to increase its
value, not just estimate its value.
You're a consultant working with a
company. Again, your job is to increase
value. So, we're going to talk about
those levers.
The last session, so called the grand
finale, we're going to take all of this,
and then I'm going to use your
valuations. For the moment, I'll leave
it at that. Of the companies you picked
as my vehicle to talk about, hey, why do
we get what we get? What do we find?
What can we draw from this?
It's too late late for preseason prep,
but I sent you this email 2 weeks ago.
You know, but if your accounting is
weak, your statistics is shaky,
you're still wrestling with that present
value button on your calculator or
computer, it's time
to get ahead of the game, right?
So, if you find yourself,
you know,
wondering what's the difference between
gross income and operating income. And
if I've already set loose the dogs of
war in your head. That's That's a good
signal that maybe you need to revisit
your accounting.
If you're saying, "Well, when should we
use averages and when should we use
medians?" That's not a finance question.
It's a statistics question. So, I've
created these short classes which would
make a purist in any of those
disciplines blanch because I break every
rule in the book because this is
accounting, statistics, and foundations
as I see it as necessary for the class.
Take advantage of that.
I will torture you.
Starting today, you've already got three
emails in case you haven't checked,
right?
Starting today, you will get an email
every day until May 5th.
Those of you in my corporate finance
class know this process.
Except for the spring break, I will give
you 7 days off. Very biblical. I will
let you kind of have the sabbatical from
my emails, but every day. What will
those emails contain? After class today,
I'll send an email about this is what we
did in class today. You're saying, "I
was in class already. Why is he sending
me the email?" You were physically in
class, but maybe mentally you took a
walk in the park or wherever else you
went, right?
So, just a matter of this
Tomorrow, you'll send the valuation of
the week. So, tomorrow I'll send you my
S&P 500 valuation and give you the
Google shared spreadsheet and then say,
"Go to town on it."
Incidentally, I'm going to open this up
to both the undergraduate and the MBA
class and to the rest of the world. So,
don't be surprised to see the numbers
mount up because other people are coming
in and putting their perspective.
On Wednesday,
after the class,
in addition to sending you a regular
email covering the class, I'll give you
what's called a weekly challenge. You're
saying, "What's the weekly challenge?"
We'll take whatever we did in that week,
Monday and Wednesday,
and the weekly challenge, I will test to
see if you can take it to the next
level. Not just the mechanical, but did
you get the concept right? Completely
optional.
I mean, people have described this class
as trying to drink out of a water hose
because there's so much stuff coming at
you. Pick and choose your battles. So,
if you can do a weekly challenge, try it
out. It's actually kind of But, but if
you have to miss it, not the end of the
world. Thursday,
I'll send you an update about the
project, this project I keep talking
about.
The purpose of update is singular. It's
to make you feel guilty.
And here's why. The valuations are not
due till May 5th. There's an
intermediate step I'll talk about where
you can do
and turn it in for feedback, but the
actual
Which means you're going to be tempted
to keep putting it off and putting it
off and putting it off. And all this
email will do is this is where you're
supposed to be on this project.
Then you can fill in the rest. This is
where I am. This is a big difference. I
need to move quickly.
It almost never works on everybody, so
there'll be people who are still picking
companies in week 14.
Nothing I can do about that, but the
project email will basically say this is
where you should be. On Friday, I will
do a web cast basically on some
practical aspect of valuation.
How do you come up with a pure group?
So, I'll go through Capital IQ, download
companies at least This is the process.
Again, because it's a practical thing
you run into evaluation the first time
you do it and you're saying, "Do I do it
by SIC codes? And I So, this is about
the practical steps in valuation. So,
webcast will cover. On Saturday,
there'll be a newsletter. What will
cover? The news for the week, which is
not much news.
But essentially, think of it as a GPS.
Now, it's a class of reasonable size,
not as big as my corporate finance
class. My undergraduate class is 350.
That class, people are going to get
lost. They'll have no idea where they
are in the class.
This will just tell you this is the page
in the lecture notes we're in. This is
where we're going to be next week. So,
it's not going to be news in the newsy
sense, but basically keeping you
grounded where the class is at that
point in time.
On Sunday, I'll send you the solution to
the weekly challenge from Wednesday.
It's completely optional, so if you
didn't do the weekly challenge, there's
probably no point
looking at the solution, or maybe that's
what he does. You look at the challenge,
you don't do it, you look at the
solution, you treat it as another
problem that got done. Now, but I'll
leave that to you given how much time
you might be able to spend in the class.
In terms of class material,
it's going to be almost entirely in the
lecture notes.
Three packets, you got the first packet,
you the all three packets are updated.
Collectively, I think there are almost
700 plus slides.
Um
but
download the packets, you know, you
don't have to print them because you can
do them you can keep them on your iPad,
you can keep them on Okay, they're
available both in PowerPoint and PDF.
The nice thing about the PowerPoint is
they come with the notes page, but the
not-so-nice thing about PowerPoint is
first, it's files are big much bulkier,
and for whatever reason, Microsoft PC
PowerPoint doesn't
behave well with Microsoft Mac
PowerPoint. Don't It doesn't always
convert. So, when you download the
PowerPoint, it might give you terrifying
messages like your file is damaged, do
you want to repair it? Just repair it.
Seems to do okay. I had to run through
it when I downloaded it onto this
because I have a Mac and this is a PC.
It'll also tell you there's it has
links to outside files that might be
dangerous. Trust me, I haven't hidden
any things in there to track you for the
rest of your life. So, if you're willing
to get past those scary-looking message,
you can do the PowerPoint.
The PDF files are much cleaner. You
don't have the font problems you have,
so you can download the PDF files.
They're smaller, they're more compact,
easier to work with.
Class rules, try to be in class. I
prefer I will make it easy for you not
to be in class because I'm always
looking for ways to disrupt myself.
What does that mean? Every class is
going to be zoomed. Right now, the the
Zoom link.
And it will be recorded.
So, can you take this class by never
coming
physically to class?
No.
In which case the question I'm asking
you is, why are you paying $250
per session? Because I'm giving that
chance to everybody outside in the rest
of the world. They're going to be able
to watch the recording. So, you're
paying this money, might as well get
some value for the money. So, I'm not
going to take attendance. I'm not going
to hold it against you if you don't show
up in class, but I'd really, really like
to see you in class.
Okay.
So, if you miss a class, no excuses. The
class recording is there, you can catch
up. You can be in another part of the
world. You can be in an interview. I
understand you might not be able to make
the class at the time it start.
But don't fall behind three or four
sessions, cuz the hill you're climbing
will get steeper and steeper the more
you let yourself get behind.
Do you need a book? Absolutely not.
But if I were taking this class, I
wouldn't buy my own book.
Why? Because it's so obscenely
overpriced.
The book that's most closely connected
to this class is Investment Valuation.
The fourth edition just came out.
Wiley reached out and said I we can send
you copies of the first edition at 50%
discount.
I said, "How much is it after the 50%
discount?" They said, "$58." And I said,
"Not interested."
It's like a hundred plus dollars.
Is it good to have? No, if that's the
way you want to keep up with the class,
it is a nice thing to have. But if you
have the third edition, fine. If you
found a version that was pirated outside
a train station in India, that's okay,
too. You know,
whatever rings your bell, I'm okay with
it. You know, but if you don't want any
So, I five books, basically, and if you
go in it'll tell you what the books the
differences are. The little book,
obviously, is this little. So, it takes
this 1,000-plus pages Investment
Valuation does it in 230 pages.
The dark side is about valuing difficult
to value companies. We got the core
stuff all nailed down. You can get it
from the lecture notes. The dark side
can supplement it.
Narrative and numbers is about
connecting stories to numbers.
And the modern evaluation is my most ego
driven choice of title. It's actually
the very first book I wrote.
And my publisher said, "Why don't you
put your name on it?" I said, "Nobody
knows me in this. Can I put O.J. Simpson
on value?" This is when the trial was
going on. Would sell more books. He
said, "No, no, you have to put your
name." But that's a book that's for
practitioners. It's about things like
illiquidity discounts and control
premiums. So, pick your poison, but if
you don't want to buy any of the books,
you can you're perfectly okay with just
the lecture notes.
Now, in terms of if you have an Apple
device, how many of you have Apple
devices?
I do, too.
You go to the App Store and you type in
new value. There's an app that you can
download for your iPhone or your iPad,
which will basically evaluation app.
Comes with a money-back guarantee.
You know why?
It's free. You don't like it, tough. You
can have your money back. It's worth
nothing.
It was built with my friend Anand Sudhir
who teaches Dartmouth for one reason and
one reason alone. To show that much of
what you get as valuations from
investment banks and appraisers is
mechanical.
So, this is an app you put in 12 numbers
in your company, it'll turn out an
intrinsic valuation that I'll put up
against any banking intrinsic valuation
of a company.
Essentially a reminder that, you know,
disruption is waiting around the corner.
You're an Excel ninja. How long do you
think I need you?
Right?
You're doing mechanical stuff. A machine
is always going to be better. If you get
a chance, you might want to read this
post I had called Beat Your Bot.
About
every one of you has a bot looking over
your shoulder. And that bot got more
powerful today than Friday. You know
why?
Cuz it can be turned loose at the world,
that's less money.
And your job will be to figure out what
you can do that your bot can't do.
So, as a final links, you know, the
webpage for the class, this is going to
be the platform where you can find
pretty much everything for the class,
not Brightspace. So, come here. There
will be stuff you can go find in
Brightspace, but it'll be peripheral
stuff. This is going to be the place
where all the material is. The YouTube
channel is where all the lectures will
go on as a playlist for the class.
Every email I send you, I know what's
going to happen. You're going to
probably block me after the second week
cuz I'm just
inundating your email box.
And you're going to claim you never got
that email that I sent on February 5th
of 2025.
It's not going to work because every
email I send will go into the
chronicles.
And there will be February 1st. So, you
can't say, "Look, I didn't I don't care
if you didn't get it." It's in there.
You can check it. So, this is
basically my way of staying making sure
that that you are connected to me in
terms of getting stuff done for the
class.
There's a Google calendar for the class
which tells you when the quizzes are.
There are three quizzes and a final
exam. The three quizzes are 10% a piece.
The final exam is 30%.
I know life gets in the way that you
might have to miss a quiz.
And if you miss a quiz, the score will
always be moved to the remaining
quizzes. So, you don't lose the 10%, but
only to the remaining quizzes. Can't be
moved back.
I've been teaching 40 years. I've seen
the gaming that can go on here.
Cuz I don't want strategic quiz missing.
You know what that means? You do very
well in the first two quizzes, you're
going to be tempted to miss the third
quiz because then it makes your first
two quizzes
have higher weights. In this class, that
doesn't happen. It just goes to the
final exam. Okay?
But if you miss a quiz, it's not the end
of the world. Do it for good reasons.
What are good reasons? I think I've
listed the good reasons here. So, go
down the reasons.
Right?
But the honest truth is if you want to
lie to me, I'm not going to So, if you
say I'm sick, I'm not going to send a
doctor to your apartment to see if
you're really sick or ask for a doctor's
note. I'll assume that you're telling me
the truth.
So, you really want to miss a quiz, you
can find a good reason. At least
do me the service of coming up with a
good reason,
even if it's a lie.
Don't say the one reason I don't want to
say I don't feel ready, even if that's a
reason.
Make up another one, okay?
So, my pet died is not good reason or
even if you don't have a pet, I don't
know if checking.
So, in terms of other stuff, there's my
blog in which I dabble. So, I've sent
you the first three data updates for the
year and sometime in the next week I
plan to write a piece on
how
the world changed over the weekend. What
does it mean for companies in the AI
ecosystem?
I have a Twitter feed, but it's just for
me to tell you something is happening. I
don't engage on Twitter. So, don't start
a debate with me on Twitter because
it'll be a one-sided debate. I will let
you talk yourself into a hole.
And the reason I don't debate on Twitter
is nothing good ever happens when you
debate on Twitter.
You end up with the least common
multiple driving the process and I have
no desire to go there.
And if you still find yourself with time
in your hands, there are more readings.
Mostly from Wall Street Journal,
Fortune, Forbes, etc.
Here's the unpleasant stuff. I know I
could tell you grades don't matter, but
we know that's a lie. So, this is the
process. Every finance class is covered
by this distribution.
So, about 25% to 30%, maybe even 35%
A's, 50% to 55% B's, and there will be
C's, D's, and F's, but you have to
really, really work to get there.
Right?
Which means you miss the quizzes, you
don't follow through on the project.
Now, so those are to ways you get there.
Try not to go that route.
So, the dates are listed here. The
evaluation project is due in two parts
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that next class to start the class.
And the quiz dates are listed. The final
exam, the date is I think finally in
place. I'll put that on the Google
calendar as well.
And uh
ground rules are basically there on how
you can miss a quiz. As I said, if you
want to make up a reason, at least make
up a reason that's on this list. It is
open book, open notes,
and open laptop. Uh let me take that
back. Open laptop, I can't do because
you're beeping. Open iPads, you know,
devices, because many of you will have
your lecture notes on those devices. If
you have your lecture notes in your
computer and you want to use it, just
don't open up Excel in a computer
because not because it's going to give
you some
great advantage, but because
you have this many people in a room like
this all with PCs open and
it can be messy, but it's open book,
open notes, open devices.
Okay.
That's about it. I will see you on
Wednesday.